hello everybody and Happy New Year I'm
Walter Binet dziak and this is top five
we're starting off 2018 with
tried-and-true 90s Nickelodeon
specifically the game shows from NYX
Golden Age right who are you the name
sandy okay what do you want sandy you
said you were gonna do this list last
year I know we just got caught up with
Star Wars month in December but that's
why I'm doing it now Star Wars sucks you
suck all right I'm gonna I'm gonna get
the list started yeah this will complete
my 90s Nickelodeon trilogy last year we
covered the best 90's Nicktoons and
live-action shows while we'll still
probably go over individuals series from
this time period in mix history the
three main aspects of the channel I
wanted to talk about were Nicktoons
live-action series and the game shows
these game shows were just as big a part
of mix identity stretching all the way
back to the 80s they involve the kids
who watch the channel and it was always
great to see ourselves reflected in the
contestants playing the games there are
very few things I wanted more in life
than to be a contestant on one of these
shows they look like so much fun alas I
never did make it to Nickelodeon studios
in Orlando Florida but the memories of
these shows and the atmosphere of pure
joy that surrounded them are as palpable
today as they were when I watched them
initially there were a lot of these
programs on Nick at the time but which
were the very best ones let's find out
these are the top 5 best 90s Nickelodeon
game shows number 5 figure it out
they brought this back in 2012 but the
original was a nice weird little
gameshow filled with slime
figure it out was hosted by summer
Sanders and featured panelists from
other Nickelodeon shows kids with hidden
talents competed as contestants as the
celebrity panel attempted to guess the
words that describe their town on a big
display board called bill the answer
head for every one of these three single
minute round the panelists didn't guess
the contestants talent he or she would
walk away with a prize there were plenty
of little rules within that game that
made it unique in the second round they
would implement a secret slime action
this would be anything from talking to
ask me the contestant a specific
question if any of the panelists
unknowingly perform the secret slime
action they'd get slimed with that
glorious green goop they'd also send out
unique clues and the charade brigade to
help the panelists throughout the game
it was cool to see these Knicks stars
outside of how we usually saw them the
show was a fun and loose game that was
easy to watch most of the time I know
how to do one nobody cares
[Music]
later we'll do it later the kids talents
also weren't always so special New York
and I can
but overall it was fun and created not
nearly as good as the other entries on
this list but you could always count and
figure it out for a funny watchable
experience moving on to number 4 the
secret slime action is ending the show
number four kid me plus videogames yeah
this was a must watch whenever I caught
it Nick arcade was hosted by Fillmore
and featured two sets of two-person
teams going head-to-head they
implemented topical questions and video
games into the early rounds with a
winning team entering the video zone
there they would face off against the
virtual video game wizard of the day for
a chance at the grand prize out of all
the game shows in this video this is the
one that I'm least familiar with it only
ran for two seasons in the early 90s and
reruns until 1997 for some reason I was
just never around when it was on though
whenever I did see it I got very excited
because it was so rare for me to catch a
glimpse of the early rounds were pretty
cool with the kids playing arcade games
and whatnot but what made this show so
great was that you could actually go
inside a video game in the final round
[Music]
frozen who's gonna have to kind of haul
it across the bridge BAM two down three
power units left yeah the video zone was
just the best I wish the whole show was
like that it made it stand out from
other knick game shows and is the main
reason why it's remembered so fondly
nowadays that effect isn't so special
but back then into a kid it seemed like
reality and virtual reality collided for
our viewing pleasure this show might do
great with a modern reboot what do you
think number three
[Music]
[Applause]
I know this is technically an ad show
but it aired until 93 so I'm counting
super sloppy double dare family double
dare whatever incarnation you're most
familiar with this was the staple of
Nickelodeon game shows for years it
featured two teams answering trivia
questions that allowed the time led to
physical challenges eventually the team
with the most money would try their luck
at the final challenge
obstacle course it was always messy but
we loved it double dare is remembered
well among those who tuned in to see
double dare had Bar None the best game
show host in channel history marc
summers was and is still the man I
really enjoyed his banter with the
contestants and camaraderie he had with
the other on-screen regulars he was just
a joy also loved him on what would you
do now Greg you have the most
interesting career change you started
off doing what I was a missionary in
Japan now I buy weapons of mass
destruction for the US government
the show did live on after its final
episode aired in 1993 it was resurrected
as double dare 2000 at the turn of the
century and even had a reunion with the
original cast in 2016 there are rumors
floating around that the show could
still be resurrected on Nick at Nite
with adult contestants I don't know
about you but I'd watch that in a second
number two do you have it
guts was hosted by Mike O'Malley and
refereed by morick work it was an action
sports competition show that featured
three young athletes facing off in
several extreme challenges they would
accumulate points until the finale a
race up a mountain called the AG broke
rep for the fourth season it was renamed
global guts and included athletes from
all over the world the show was also
briefly resurrected as my family's got
guts and aired from 2008 to 2009 this is
definitely one of those shows I was
dying to get on guts had a catchy theme
song a good host great events and of
course the aggro crag where almost
anything can happen our players will get
a lot of surprises as they make their
way up that mountain snow storm smoke
slime water in their eyes a whole bunch
of actuators to hit falling rocks yeah
that thing was badass the aggro crag
kept evolving as the seasons went on and
it was always fun seeing these kids
compete
the thing about guts was that it was
kind of dangerous I'm sure the kids and
their parents knew the risks but man it
could get pretty brutal but honestly
that made me love it more this show was
no joke
[Music]
and the number one best 90s Nickelodeon
game show is legend sulfa he did temple
red Jaguar Stern life legends of the
Hidden Temple was an action-adventure
game show that combined history
obstacles and challenges to create
something very unique a giant talking
head named Olmec was the keeper of the
legendary temple and provided many of
the facts about what the contestants
were playing for Kirk Fogg hosted the
show in addition to being the team's
guide this wasn't just my favorite knick
game show this was one of my favorite
Nick shows period it had the best of
guts and added a cool theme with
different team names to claim as your
favorite the red Jaguars orange iguanas
green monkeys purple parrots silver
snakes and blue barracudas competed on
the show for the right to enter Olmecs
temple and retrieve that episode's
precious historical item during the
temple run several temple guards waited
in the wings to capture the players
unless you had a full pendant of life
which was earned in the previous games
from the theme song to the set this show
stood out as something really remarkable
it's no wonder that its popularity has
endured in 2016 the show was made into a
TV movie that had many elements from the
original in it including hosts Kirk Fogg
himself The Legend Continues right
these game shows capped off the trifecta
that included Nicktoons and live-action
series on 90s Nickelodeon without them
it just wouldn't have been the same my
inner child is still holding out hope to
one day enter Olmecs temple or even
climb the agro crack well a guy can
dream over on my personal channel you
can check out my top 5 favorite films
from 2017 and a Jumanji 95 versus
Jumanji 17 comparison video going up
soon so head on over for more content I
want to hear what you guys think what is
your favorite 90s Nickelodeon gameshow
what you want me to cover next on this
show leave a comment and let me know to
keep in touch like my facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome walter b or
follow along on twitter take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future come back next week for a
brand new episode top 5
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you